one of the key discovery we found for
palliation design is how this actually
can even help the staff better serve the
passenger those things helped us
discover new ways in which can surprise
the passengers
the outcome of t4 has achieved our
desire through creator termina embracing
the team of fun vibrant and possibly
surprising the team would be weaved into
all the touch points in the design of t4
so one passengers to go through t4 they
enjoy the whole process and thus no
stress from the moment they step in the
terminal to the moment they embarked on
the aircraft we wanted people to help
staff to do more with less to provide
better service to passengers by using
technology to take away some of the
mental processing we have injected for
many new ideas with sample Forrest's one
of them automation at a back room given
a patient's system is also designed
differently to reduce the burden on
manpower now the job is easier and you
get to interact with the passenger more
so this part about cell service doesn't
mean no service is a very big belief
that we have and here I think I mean
look at what China has done for designs
as a victim you know and what we learned
from before I think for future Airport
is really designing Airport as a
definition of lifestyle as a place that
symptoms will feel proud of who have a
sense of ownership and a place where
Singaporeans will care is only that they
care that we think Changi Airport was a
sea
you
[Music]